here's the problem women have when they
grow up without a father figure is
they'll always date a lot older men now
my experience of working with women that
go for these age Gap relationships is
they are in survival mode without a
father they need that safety and comfort
and the conversations that we normally
find really boring coming from our
father about mortgage rates and saving
your money they sexualize those
conversations so when they hear it from
an older man they're like oh he's so
responsible so they end up initially
going for the old man falling in love
but once they feel safe and they've got
the money and they got the safety they
then look for men around their own age
once you've got an older Father Figure
in your life then you go on to see what
you're sexually attracted to they end up
looking for it in an older man but then
cheating on him with a younger man do
you think that they over prioritize
socioeconomic status rightly so I
understand why because they don't have a
backup plan and usually if they come
from a single mom home she's also
encouraging her to look for a rich man
because it benefits her as well so they
come from a culture of you don't have to
love a man all men are annoying and
they're difficult so just choose one
that's going to give you a good life
again she ends up with a man that she
doesn't respect in the long run